good morning believe nation today's
message is do your research over to you
Peter Lynch the public when they buy a
refrigerator they get a Consumer Reports
they buy a microwave oven they do that
they ask people what's the best kind of
radar range or what kind of car to buy
they do research on the apartments and
they go to when they go on a trip to
Wyoming they get a mobile Travel Guide
or California when they go to Europe
they get the Michelin Travel Guide
people will hear a tip on the bus on
some stock and they'll put half their
life savings in it before sunset and
they wonder why they lose money the
stock market and when they lose money
they blame it on the institutions of
program training that is garbage they
didn't do any research that but if
there's a job they do into the balance
sheet and that's what you get for it and
that's what we were being driven to and
it's self fulfilling the public does
terrible investing and they say they
don't have a chance it's because that's
the way they way they're acting so have
a couple thoughts on this the first and
maybe the most obvious is you want to do
your research before you get into any
project right you want to understand the
market you want to talk to customers you
want to understand the price and
understand the competitors too many
people just kind of jump into something
and spend a ton of money on it and then
it doesn't work out because it didn't do
their research to me that's really the
most obvious answer the second thing
around doing your research is also I
think you can do research by trying just
don't try on a big scale right it's ok
to try because you can only get so much
information from researching online
right and looking at the reports at some
point you have to actually do right just
don't spend an insane amount of money
doing and see if it makes you come alive
see if you like it right say you want to
start a YouTube channel I could do all
the research in the world about how to
start a YouTube channel and yes it's
growing and yes there's lots of
opportunities and yes you can impact our
lives and yes you can make a lot of
money
great now you're actually gotta go out
and do you got to execute and maybe you
start and you hate it like maybe you get
in front of the camera it's like oh this
isn't what I thought it was or I don't
want to do all that editing work and and
the dream kind of falls apart
that's great you move on to something
else but part of the research is
actually doing and testing and not going
out and spending tons of money on the
gear and the camera and the editing
equipment and all of that stuff you
don't have to worry about any of it
start the smallest way possible doing
your research includes testing it out on
a small scale and in my last thought on
this is I think it's also important to
understand that your customers are doing
their research too you know one of the
things we do and pay a lot of attention
to at Toronto then salsa is our Google
reviews right because people are
searching for dance schools when we show
up number one with SEO but there's also
tons of great and positive reviews on
Google and you know on Yelp and a
different sites and so understanding
that your customers are doing research
to find you and so are you accessible
are you reachable do you have good data
out there are you given the white papers
and are you educated are you telling
your story are you sharing your mission
so that when people see it and they're
doing their research they find you know
you like you trust you and want to work
with you
so touching a few points there the
question today is how do you do your
research leave it in the comments below
I'm gonna join the discussion thank you
guys so much for watching
have an amazing day continue to believe
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso